roller drum is similar to roll seven's
other titles in that it's a single
player skating game that emphasizes
performing tricks but this isn't just an
olly olly game with guns
[Music]
volodrome issues the side-scrolling
nature of roll 7's famous platformer
series for fully 3d skatepark like
arenas as you skate through a single
area you must utilize walls and ramps to
loop yourself around and to perform
tricks populating this arena are enemies
that spawn in various locations meaning
that while you're doing your manuals and
flips you also have to take down bat
wielding melee fighters and distant
snipers who want you dead also
differentiating roller drum from olly
olly is the fact that the former is not
a skateboarding game but rather a roller
skating game set in the future as
imagined through the lens of the 1970s
roller drum draws heavily from the sport
of roller derby while also taking
inspiration from the 1975 james khan
movie rollerball which was about a near
future bloodsport run by a corporation
with nefarious intentions that's pretty
much what's going on in roller drum too
the focus in roller drum is on the
competition which sees your lone skater
enter an arena where they have to clear
out several waves of house players who
have a smart ring of weapons of their
own your goal is to clear out all the
house players as quickly as you can but
the enemies all have different guns and
quirks for how you have to deal with
them you start the game with a pair of
pistols and slowly unlock more guns
through the course of roller drums short
campaign up to a total of four all the
guns are fairly effective in every
situation but each one has situational
advantages the low damage pistols are
good for staggering an enemy or
finishing off someone the slow shotgun
can fire well-timed slug rounds that do
one big hit of damage the grenade
launcher can hit multiple enemies but is
tough to keep stocked with ammo and the
railgun can hit enemies from great
distances but only if your aim is
precise
the combat portion of the game is
smartly designed to make you feel cool
as you make lots of tactical decisions
without requiring much in the way of
twitch reflexes or intense shooter
skills the focus is on maintaining
momentum and planning your moves through
the arena so skating and aiming are both
handled automatically you only have to
steer and as long as you're close enough
to your phone your bullets will hit them
you can also slow down time for a brief
period by holding down a shoulder bun
which allows you a little more precision
in your targeting without disrupting the
fluidity of your skating much more
important is picking the right gun for
the job enemies with riot shields are
best stunned with the grenade launcher
and mopped up with a shotgun for
instance while the constant barrage of
bullets from your pistols can do a lot
of damage to teleporting enemies before
they have a chance to escape the railgun
can quickly take out the jetpacks of
airborne enemies before they can get the
upper hand on you and the best way to
deal with the more fortified foes who
fire rockets is to shoot their
projectile and then follow up with your
fastest guns
as the game progresses to situations you
find yourself in get excitingly hectic
you'll be under assault from big batches
of house players who shoot back at you
and their aim is just as good as yours
you have a dodge ability that briefly
makes you invincible to help keep
yourself alive and if you time it
correctly it will give you bonus damage
on your shots you also gain health from
enemies you kill but you have to be
close enough to collect it fighting in
roller drum is all about constant
planning where you're headed next which
targets you want to prioritize how to
move through the arena to keep yourself
alive and which weapons to use for each
situation as it comes up it gives roller
drum an aggressive cerebral aspect that
pairs perfectly with its fast pace
action you're a top tier competitor
because you're not only great at skating
through the arena but also constantly
analyzing it
where roller drum really excels is in
mixing all these combat ideas with the
skating action that roll seven is known
for the underlying premise is that each
arena is something like a tony hawk's
pro skater level and whenever you're not
shooting enemies you're trying to do
sick tricks these two elements of the
game can feel at odds with each other
why are you stopping to do backflips
when people are shooting laser death
rays at you but the game brilliantly
combines its trick-based skating
gameplay with its shooter combat you
have limited ammo for your weapons and
all your guns share the exact same ammo
pull so if you go ham with your pistols
you won't have any grenade launcher
shells waiting when the magazines are
empty the only way to restore your ammo
is by doing tricks and the cooler the
trick the more ammo you're rewarded with
by the roller drum judges the ammo
system makes the skating mechanics an
essential part of shooting and coupled
with other useful additions like the
time slowing focus system it never feels
like the tricks are an impediment to the
shooting instead there's a secret
ingredient that helps roll a drum stand
apart from other shooters
the ammo system adds another wrinkle to
the focus on planning in order to keep
killing enemies you have to do killer
tricks so you're not only making your
way through the arena to take down
priority targets while dodging incoming
fire and keeping yourself alive you're
also sizing up where the ramps are or
whether a grind rail will take you past
your intended targets or whether you can
do a wall ride up to a better vantage
point to fire off a grenade it's an
intelligent combination of systems that
mixes two very different kinds of play
together to make a game that works much
better than you might think it should
doing flips over the heads of enemies
slowing down time and blasting them
before they can react is awesome every
single time quickly dodging a sniper
round only to follow up with a powerful
attack of your own always makes you feel
like you have a complete mastery of
roller drums arenas and a focus on
ever-present momentum gives the game a
kineticism that means that action never
stops messing up a jump or blowing a
grind just means your character
automatically does a somersault back to
their feet to keep moving you never have
to stop to think about things that will
distract you from the much more engaging
problems of how to pull off your next
trick or take down your next opponent
if there's a drawback to roller drum
it's that it naturally hits a skill
plateau that's tough to move past like
alioli and tony hawk roller drone puts a
big premium on racking up the most
points you can and smartly combines the
shooting and trick mechanics to make
them essential for climbing its online
leader boards tricks score you points
but killing enemies creates combos and
drives multipliers so you need to be
doing both in tandem to really put up
numbers trick controls are generally
simple and easy to do under pressure
grabs are executed by pushing a
direction on the control stick with a
face button and more elaborate tricks
take an extra movement swipe or two to
pull off the speed needed to execute
those tougher tricks results in them not
being particularly reliable though so i
found i really was able to work in the
more involved items of the trictionary
especially at the height of intensity in
a match once i started getting good at
roller drum i felt like i couldn't
really get much better keeping combos
going and killing enemies to raise your
multipliers is a huge part of earning a
high score but i got a little tired of
pulling the same 5 or 10 tricks over and
over and could never seem to get the
tougher ones to activate when i actually
wanted them to
roller drum also contains an initially
engaging first person narrative
component that winds up being
disappointingly inconsequential you play
a new competitor on the roller drum
circuit trying to make a name for
yourself among the stars of the sport
matterhorn the corporation behind
rolodrome is using the sport's
popularity to consolidate its power
lobbying the government to take control
of the country's police forces while
protesters push back against its
influence rivalries between players
political machinations and conspiracies
playing in the background are all
revealed by news reports notes and clues
you find in the locations you visit such
as the locker room before a match or a
tv studio while you await an interview
the little tidbits flesh out the world
and you even have a few small choices to
make along the way unfortunately though
those choices and the story don't amount
to much other than a little bit of color
added to your death match play most of
the plot is vague impressions implied by
items in the environment like the fact
that one competitor is arrested for
their ties to an anti-matterhorn
political group and it all goes about
where you'd expect you can make some
minor choices about where you might
stand on the political situation but
those choices don't seem to affect
anything either way you fight to become
the new roller drum champion and when
you manage to do so you go back to
competing in tougher versions of roller
drums matches in the subsequent season
the ideas and presentation of the plot
add a lot to the game in an understated
way and it's just tantalizing enough to
leave you wishing there was more
still roller drum is a blast to play
especially if you get the hang of its
systems and really start to hit the flow
state roll seven is trying to achieve
revisiting old matches and wiping the
floor with house players for 20 or 30
times multipliers is extremely
satisfying and doing backflips over
enemies while you blast them with a
shotgun always looks and feels
incredibly cool occasionally aspects of
roller drum can be a little too simple
for their own good but overall the game
is a brilliant melding of systems that
don't seem like they should work
together but in practice combines
excellent elements of skaters and
shooters to elevate both
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
wow
[Music]
victory